>> Sean: WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY KAYLEIGH McENANY
ISN’T PULLING ANY PUNCHES WITH
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I END WITH THIS.
I WAS ASKED 12 QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE CONFEDERATE FLAG.
THIS PRESIDENT FOCUSED ON
ACTION.
I’M A LITTLE DISMAYED THAT I
DIDN’T RECEIVE ONE QUESTION
WRONG THE DEATH WE GOT IN THIS
COUNTRY THIS WEEKEND.
>> Sean: IT IS SUCH A GOOD
POINT, WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE SHOT EVERY WEEKEND.
ANYONE WANTS TO HAVE A DEBATE
ABOUT MEMORIALS OR STATUES, I AM
OPEN FOR DEBATE WITH ANYBODY.
CAN WE DO IT WHILE WE ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY PROTECTING THE
LIFE OF EVERY AMERICAN CITIZEN
AND EVERY CITY AND TOWN IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OUR KIDS ARE NOW
DYING AT SIX, SEVEN, AND EIGHT
FROM BULLETS IN THEIR HEAD.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I WENT BACK AND COUNTED ON MY
WAY HERE, WAS ASKED MORE THAN 24
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CONFEDERATE
FLAG, NOT ONE ABOUT THESE
CHILDREN AND GOOD ON YOU TO SHOW
THE PICTURES OF THESE KIDS.
WE NEED TO KNOW THEIR FACES,
KNOW THEIR NAMES.
LOST HER LIFE IN ATLANTA, THIS
IS A TRAGEDY.
THIS IS HAPPENING ON AMERICAN
STREETS BECAUSE OF DEMOCRAT
MAYORS AND DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS
AND THEIR FUNDAMENTAL AN
INTEREST IN GETTING TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
IS DESPICABLE AND IT JUST GOES
TO SHOW HOW OUT OF TOUCH PEOPLE
ARE HERE.
>> Sean: IT WAS A GREAT IDEA,
PONDERING EVERYBODY, RACES,
BACKGROUNDS, SO YOU HAVE
COMBINED OVER 125 YEARS
EXPERIENCE, STUPID ENOUGH AS A
COUNTRY TO ELECT BIDEN, PELOSI,
AND SCHUMER.
THEY DIDN’T DO OPPORTUNITY
ZONES, THEY DIDN’T DO CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM OR POLICE REFORM.
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
THEY DIDN’T SHATTER RECORD AFTER
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
MINORITIES IN AMERICA AND THEY
HAD EIGHT YEARS TO DO IT.
WHY DID THEY DO IT?
ACTIONS IN SUCCESS OR ANOTHER.
>> MAKING PERMANENT HBCUS
FUNDING, CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, BUT WHAT DO DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO ON OFFER?
TWO CHILDREN DIED IN AUTONOMOUS
ZONE, FAILED CITIES LIKE CHICAGO
WHERE YOU SAW 13 KILLED LAST
WEEKEND, 77 INJURED LIKE
NEW YORK CITY WHERE YOU’VE HAD
FOR THREE WEEKS AND INCREASING
SHOOTINGS.
THIS IS WHERE IT HAS GOTTEN US
AND THE BLACK COMMUNITY IN
PARTICULAR, POVERTY, CRIME AND
THE CITIES, AND TAKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RESCUE PEOPLE
FROM THAT SCENARIO AND GIVE HOPE
AND OPPORTUNITY.
>> Sean: I NOTICED THE MOB IS
CRITICIZING "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AND OTHERS AND I’M THINKING THAT
MEANS YOU’RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
DOES IT BOTHER YOU AT ALL?
>> I TAKE IT AS A BADGE OF
HONOR.
GUESS WHAT THAT MEANS?
I AM GETTING TO THEM, PUSHING
THEIR BUTTONS, NOT GOING TO PLAY
THEIR GAME LIKE THEY PLAY WITH
ANY REPUBLICAN WHO COMES TO THIS
TOWN.
THE TRUTH IS THAT THIS PRESIDENT
HAS DONE SO MUCH FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND THEY DON’T GET
ENOUGH CREDIT BUT WE WILL GIVE
CREDIT.
>> Sean: GREAT JOB, AND I KNOW